anyone who wants to understand vladimir
putin needs to know the story of what
happened to him one night in east
germany 33 years ago it was december 5
1989 just a few weeks after the berlin
wall fell in east germany communism was
dead although free democratic elections
weren't scheduled until the spring in
the east german city of dredsden
protesters stormed the regional
headquarters of the east german secret
police the stasi completely overrunning
the office then a small group of
protesters reportedly no more than 20
decided to head across the road to the
local headquarters of the soviet secret
service the kgb
russian media later exaggerated the
number of demonstrators to five thousand
putin anticipated the protester his
arrival and called for help from the
soviet military stationed in east
germany to protect the employees in the
office as well as the files they had an
informant in agents they tried to burn
as many of the files as possible and
even broke the furnace but the red army
was not coming to the rescue in his
biography first person putin recalled
being told on the phone we cannot do
anything without orders from moscow and
moscow is silent those words moscow is
silent stayed with them because it
finally dawned on him that the soviet
union had all but disappeared now it was
up to putin to figure out how to get
himself and his kgb colleagues out of
that dangerous situation how could he
stop the crowd from swarming the
building in an interview with the bbc
one of the protesters siegfried dannath
recalled how when the mob approached the
kgb house the guard immediately rushed
inside shortly afterward an officer
emerged quite small agitated that
officer was 37 year old kgb lieutenant
colonel vladimir putin except he didn't
say he was a spy putin said he was a
translator he told the crowd in fluent
german that the property was on soviet
territory according to the protester
putin said to the group don't try to
force your way into this property my
comrades are armed and they're
authorized to use their weapons in an
emergency
putin was bluffing but the mob believed
him and backed away leaving staff and
the sensitive files unscathed
long before vladimir putin became
president of russia he fulfilled his
teenage wish of becoming a kgb agent
inspired by the books he read in films
he watched he spent five years stationed
in the isolated east german city of
dresden from 1985 to 1989. east germany
was important to moscow it was a
satellite state of the soviet union that
sat on the doorstep of nato the western
military alliance we don't have much
information about what kind of work
putin did in dresden he said little
about his work in the 80s other than
speaking about that december day in 1989
what he witnessed was humiliating he saw
the west winning the cold war as the
eastern bloc crumbled under his feet the
atlantic wrote putin's experience in
dresden undoubtedly reinforced his view
of his identity and role as the critical
outsider learning from the mistakes of
others soviet leader mikhail gorbachev
failed to prevent the subsequent
collapse of the soviet union in 1991 one
of the largest and most powerful empires
in history unraveled breaking up into 15
nations leaving russia a shadow of its
former self putin called it the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe of the 20th
century
he later claimed he knew the collapse
was inevitable quote i understood that a
position based on walls and water
barriers cannot exist forever but i
wanted something different to rise in
its place and nothing different was
proposed that's what hurt putin never
rose to the top ranks of the kgb he
remained a mid-level agent on the
periphery in the 90s he left the kgb to
become deputy mayor of st petersburg and
by the late 90s he transferred to moscow
to work in president boris yeltsin's
administration he was picked to lead the
new federal security service which
replaced the kgb and then he was
surprisingly chosen by yeltsin as prime
minister in 1999 he saw how weak russia
had become when president bill clinton
approved airstrikes against serbian
forces in bosnia washington didn't even
consult yeltsin the serbs share deep
ethnic and religious ties with russia
putin's leadership would be very
different from yeltsin's when he took
over as president in 2000 he impressed
clinton's point man on russia strobe
talbot the u.s deputy secretary of state
who wrote in his memoirs that he was
struck by putin's ability to convey
self-control in confidence in a low-key
soft-spoken manner putin's image though
is anything but low-key he's frequently
photographed doing super manly things
like fishing shirtless overpowering
opponents in judo or driving race cars
the macho president has put his tough
image on display for both his fellow
countrymen and the world reinforcing the
image of a strong leader trying to build
up a strong resurgent country in 1999
just before taking office putin stressed
the importance of strengthening the
state writing in an article in the
russian newspaper nizavisimiya guiazieta
russia is in the midst of one of the
most difficult periods in its history
for the first time in the past 200 to
300 years it is facing a real threat of
sliding to the second and possibly even
third echelon of world states we are
running out of time for removing this
threat many believe his actions over the
years have been guided by one principle
to make russia great again
when russia annexed the crimean
peninsula from ukraine in 2014 it led to
a spike in putin's popularity at home
in late on february 23 2022 russia
started attacking targets all over
ukraine why the clearest answer came
from putin himself two days prior to the
attack putin delivered a speech where he
described ukraine as an illegitimate
country that it sits on historically
russian land he views ukraine as a lost
part of russia itself but ukraine
doesn't see it that way it voted
overwhelmingly to establish an
independent state and now seeks to join
nato which putin is determined to block
putin's closest aides today consist of
those from his kgb days or who have
security backgrounds they are believed
to tell him only what he wants to hear
president putin is said to want to
rebuild a sphere of influence in eastern
europe bemoaning the collapse of the
communist order which traumatized him as
a young agent in east germany in this
latest attack on ukraine a russian tank
could be seen flying the soviet flag
officially russia has dismissed the
possibility of reviving the soviet union
putting the story together from start to
finish in just a couple of days was not
easy to pull off it's really important
for me to stay as healthy as possible so
i feel good and can be as productive as
possible
my sponsor by optimizer is mineral rich
supplement magnesium breakthrough aims
to help you beat stress fatigue and
sleep better i have trouble sleeping and
for the past few months i've been taking
magnesium breakthrough myself and i've
noticed that my sleep has gotten a lot
better most magnesium supplements fail
because they're synthetic or use
preservatives when you get all seven
critical forms of magnesium your body
gets a serious upgrade so you feel
better throughout your day to find out
more go to magnesiumbreakthrough.com
newsthink to get a 10 discount be sure
to use the promo code newsthink10 at
checkout you can click my custom link in
the description or pinned comment and
try the powerful effects of magnesium
for yourself thanks for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy palm